It's 2015 and the world's most powerful drug
trafficker, El Chapo, is about to escape from prison.
Did you see it?
Right now.
He's gone.
"One of the world's richest, most notorious
drug kingpins broke out of prison."
"Former cartel leader is considered one of
the most dangerous drug traffickers in the world."
Joaquin Guzman Loera, better known as "El
Chapo", broke out of his cell by crawling
out of a hole in the shower.
The escape of Chapo Guzman translates into
two things:
More violence for Mexico
and more drugs coming into the United States.
El Chapo was the leader of the
Sinaloa Cartel, a murderous criminal organization
that has killed thousands during Mexico's
violent drug wars.
Their methods are brutal.
But violence isn't what makes El Chapo different
from other traffickers.
Instead, his legacy has been shaped by two
abilities: transporting more drugs across
the border than anyone else and always finding
a way to escape authorities.
That was, until now.
After being captured again in Mexico, El Chapo
is standing trial in the United States.
It's the latest chapter for the world's most
powerful drug trafficker and to understand
how El Chapo got here, it helps to look at
a single innovation, the one tool that El
Chapo used to transform the drug trade is
the same tool that made him its most elusive
target: tunnels.
"Tunnels."
"Through a tunnel."
"Used by El Chapo."
"Tunnel King."
"Master of tunnels."
[Spanish]: "The king of tunnels."
"Prince of tunnels."
"It's a magnificent feat of architecture and
engineering."
"Being used to smuggle drugs."
"And it's like looking for a needle in a haystack."
"There's not really any form of technology
right now that can discover these tunnels
being built."
"The tunnel.
Look at this."
In 1990, federal agents in Douglas, Arizona,
found something new: a sophisticated drug
tunnel from the US to Mexico.
And when investigators got inside it, they
were amazed by what they saw.
The tunnel was 300 feet long and lit by an
electrical system running along the wall.
At one end, a lever raised a hydraulic lift
that opened an entrance in the safehouse floor.
One agent said it was "like something out
of a James Bond movie."
In fact, it had been built by an architect
working for El Chapo.
And agents didn't know it yet, but this was
their first sign of a major shift in the US
drug trade.
In the 1980s, US drug traffic had been dominated
by cocaine coming through the Caribbean, but
during the next two decades US forces led
a crackdown which changed the drug trade in
two ways that put El Chapo in the right place
at the right time.
First, drug traffic shifted to routes through
Mexico.
Second, as national militaries worked with
the US to destroy crops in South America,
traffickers focused on drugs they could grow
elsewhere.
The coca plant is only grown in the Andes
mountains, but marijuana can be grown in Mexico,
especially in mountain ranges along the western
coast.
And the same is true for the opium poppy,
the raw ingredient processed to make heroin.
For both crops, the densest region of cultivation
includes the state of Sinaloa, the home of El Chapo.
El Chapo also had the ideal way to move those
drugs: unlike cocaine, which is odorless and
can be tightly packed into a vehicle, marijuana
is bulky and has a strong smell.
But by using his tunnels, El Chapo could get
massive amounts across the border quickly.
By 2010, El Chapo had become the most powerful
trafficker in the country.
And as the Sinaloa Cartel increased their
power, their territory expanded to include
the entire Western half of the US border.
As their control spread west, one particular
area became crucial to their operation:
a suburb of San Diego called Otay Mesa.
There are three reasons why they chose Otay
Mesa, and understanding them gives you a sense
of how sophisticated El Chapo's operation
really was.
First, it is near two major transportation
hubs, Tijuana and San Diego, so drugs can
quickly get to the border and out to dealers
on the other side.
Second, it’s an industrial area across the
border from Tijuana’s airport, meaning there’s
a steady stream of noise and traffic that
make it easy to go undetected.
The third reason, is the soil.
To the west is ocean, where the ground is
too damp,
And to the East the earth rises to become
hard mountainous rock.
Otay Mesa is located in between, and soil
maps show a geological sweet spot where the
soil is soft enough to dig by hand, but strong
enough to support a tunnel.
“Yeah, this is the stair system.
it's about a 70 foot drop."
In November 2010, agents found a tunnel in
Otay Mesa built by the Sinaloa Cartel.
Inside, electricity powered lighting and a
ventilation system.
Along the floor, a rail system allowed workers
to remove rubble during construction and then
transport drugs once they started using it.
Over the next few years, agents found more
massive tunnels.
Tunnels like these can take several months
and millions of dollars to build, but they’re
worth it.
The tunnels are so big that traffickers can
move multiple tons of drugs at once,
As the Sinaloa Cartel continued building in
Otay Mesa, their tunnels got more impressive,
like building an entrance for one beneath
a bathroom floor.
El Chapo’s tunnels are dug so deep that
ground penetrating radar can’t detect them
And at ground level, the entrances are hidden
in clever ways.
But El Chapo wasn’t only building tunnels
to smuggle drugs across the border.
In 2014, authorities raided his safehouse
in the Sinaloan capital of Culiacan, but El Chapo
escaped by fleeing through a tunnel
hidden beneath his bathtub.
A few days later, authorities tracked him
down in Mazatlan,
where El Chapo was captured
and sent to Altiplano maximum security prison.
A year later, he was gone.
This was the largest tunnel ever built by
the Sinaloa Cartel.
It stretched nearly a mile, to a farmhouse
in a nearby field..
A year before, that field had been empty.
Beneath a hole in the floor,
authorities found a motorcycle that El Chapo
had used to cruise through the tunnel in less
than ten minutes.
In Sinaloa, El Chapo’s supporters celebrated
the spectacular escape.
But his freedom was short lived.
A few months later, authorities broke into
his hideout in Los Mochis, Sinaloa, where
he was arrested after a bloody gun battle.
He escaped through a tunnel hidden behind
his mirror that led into the sewer,
but authorities caught him a few hours later
when he crawled out of a manhole and tried
to flee town.
This time he was extradited to the US,
where he is on trial in New York City.
Authorities are so serious about security
that they shut down the Brooklyn Bridge when
El Chapo is moved from his Manhattan jail
cell to the court house.
But even as he sits in jail, El Chapo’s
legacy lives on.
In 2018, two major tunnels were discovered
along the US border.
In Arizona, one stretched across from Mexico
to the back of an abandoned KFC.
And in California, authorities found an unfinished
tunnel that had been equipped with electricity
and ventilation systems that run on solar
power.
Another piece of his legacy also continues.
In 2018, drug violence contributed to more
people being murdered in Mexico than ever before.
But as aspiring kingpins add to the violence
in Mexico, El Chapo is back in his cell.
At least, for now.
Thanks for watching. If you haven't already heard,
we've launched a paid membership program called the Video Lab.
It's a great way to support our journalism and if you want to join,
you can head over to vox.com/join.